Hi, and welcome to the part of the 40 Days of Holiness Experience that we call the
Guided Prayer Experience. During this 40 days, here's my goal:
I want to create a window of opportunity, an anchor point in your
day, where you can pray and ask God to do the
things in you and seek Him to accomplish in
you the things that you learn during this 40 days.
So my goal is not to create some kind of mystical
experience, but to provide an anchor point and a demonstration
for you and a time with you of seeking God to
do what He promised He would do. I believe and have
great confidence in the promises of God for the work of
God's holiness being created in our hearts.
I think that when God says, "I want to make you holy," He was
completely sincere. But here's the catch.
Frequently, God wishes and wants and desires to do something,
but He watches to see
if our desires rise to the level of meeting
His desire for accomplishing something.
So my goal in this time is for us to create a window of time
every day, a five-minute window, where we specifically ask God to
fulfill all His promises in our hearts.
So let's do that together with great faith, with great confidence.
Here's how we're going to do it. We're going to begin every five-minute
segment with a time of praying back to God the
scriptures that we've been talking about or the theology concepts we've been
talking about, because prayer should be a conversation with God.
God speaks to us in His Word. We speak back to God about
the things He's been speaking to us about. All right?
And so we're going to begin with a time of
led and guided prayer. I'll guide you in that, and we'll pray
together. And I would encourage you to, as
the phrase is, to say the amen with me, right?
That you are in your heart engaging the things that
I'm asking and leading in prayer for, you are engaging with as
well. And then there will be a time every day at the end of the five-minute
segment where you'll have an opportunity to, in your
own words and from your own heart, turn that thought toward
God and to ask Him to accomplish all His purposes in
your soul.
I'm excited to do this together because I think it is going to be
transformational. "God does nothing but in answer to
prayer," said John Wesley. And there's a phrase in John Wesley's journal
that's so beautiful. I used it a moment ago.
He said, "I was asking God in the evening that He would fulfill
all His promises in my soul."
Let's do that. That's what we're seeking for.
So today we'll begin with a time of worship and
meditation and prayer.
Today will be a little shorter because of the extra three minutes here that I'm
describing all of this and casting the vision for it.
But we will pray together for five minutes each day over the next 40 days.
Thanks for being here.
Let's pray together over day one.
Father, you are holy.
You are pure. You are separate. You are
above. And we worship you today. Nothing can
compare with the joy of knowing you in your holiness.
We worship you as the Bible commands us to in the beauty of your
holiness.
We tremble before you. We
rejoice with trembling. We thank you for the
glory and the outshining brilliance of your holy
character.
Lord, we pray that you would, as John Wesley said,
"Fulfill all your promises in our souls."
Oh God, if you call us to be like you,
oh, what a joy to have the character of God
reproduced in us. Oh Lord, do this
miracle.
That you could take lost and sinful people and make us holy is
the greatest reality in all of the universe.
So do this for us, we pray in Jesus' name.
Now let's continue for the rest of this minute, about 60
seconds left, in prayer in your own words.